الى الان الحمد لله ما زالت العائلات تاتي
تباعا من ذلك الجانب الى قسم الهجره في
معبر باب الهواء الحدودي مع تركيا يكون
الرقم مع وصول هاتين الحافلتين قد تجاوز
ال
مسافرا نحن نتحدث عن عائلات باكملها وصلت
من عده ولايات تركيه من شان لاورفا وديار
بكر وصولا الى هاتاي مدينه انطاكيا التي
تاتي غالبيه العائلات من هذه المدينه
المنكوبه والتي تعرضت الى دمار كبير
الكثير من العائلات بحاله نفسيه سيئه
وايضا الاطفال
التعب بادي على وجوه الاطفال وعلى وجوه
المسنين هنا في معبر باب الهوى الحدودي مع
تركيا هناك كادر طبي وايضا اخصائيين
نفسيين يحاولون التعامل مع الاطفال والاسر
اضافه الى كادر من وزاره التنميه يحاول
ايضا ان يقف على احتياجات العائلات التي
وصلت الى معبر باب الهوى والحدودي ولا
وليس لها اقارب او ليس لها مكان تبيت فيه
ليقوم بتامين ايضا الماوى ربما
لواء هذه العائلات والوقوف على احتياجاتها
الكارثه كبيره والمصاب كبير بين الجانبين
السوري والتركي نتحدث ايضا عن ارقام مهوله
ما زالت خارج البوابات التركيه وما زال
الجانب التركي حقيقه يعمل الى هذه الساعه